marriage is an exclusive sexual contract
If you deny your partner sex like who is
he supposed to go get it from yeah but
even in the military you're not always
on duty you're only on due to uncertain
time like no you're always on duty
like say if you are the horse guard
you're great you only um due to while
you're standing
you get to be a wife when you feel like
it yeah what I'm trying to say is you
always use these negative words and
negative connotation like for me this is
this is part like what was negative
about doing your duty because for me
that's not a beauty it's a pleasure
what if I wanted to find pleasure what
if I wanted to find pleasure with
another woman
so then you're on duty